seis días después del desastre natural
más mortífero de este siglo la esperanza
no muere en Turquía
niños y personas mayores son rescatados
de las montañas de escombros
como
una mujer de 64 años que permaneció 150
horas bajo las ruinas de este edificio
de apartamentos en la ciudad de
hatayra de 5 años que fue rescatada
junto a su padre
rescate es insólitos que vencen el plazo
de 72 horas para encontrar
sobrevivientes después de un terremoto
cada persona ya con vida despierta el
júbilo de los rescatistas
y el asombro de los medios esta mujer
transportada en camilla estuvo instantes
de no ser rescatada
estábamos a punto de abandonar este
edificio pero quisimos hacer una última
revisión por si acaso de repente me
pareció escuchar un sonido pero no
estaba seguro si provenía del edificio o
de las personas que estaban afuera
cuando escuchamos el sonido viniendo
realmente el interior comenzamos a
trabajar pero al otro lado de la
frontera en Siria el panorama es
distinto
un silencio inquietante desmotiva las
operaciones de rescate
que ya finalizaron en áreas Del Noroeste
del país controladas por grupos Rebeldes
y fundamentalistas
no creo que haya esperanza de encontrar
sobrevivientes desde el primer día
Tratamos de salvar a tanta gente como
pudimos pero ya no hay esperanza
en un país devastado por 12 años de
guerra la defensa civil está
desfinanciada y no ha recibido equipos
nuevos de rescate